do you like your current like the first
picture that shows up
no i don't know how those work but
they're never flattering
never hey i'm nikki i'm rich brian
and today we're doing the wired auto
complete interview
yes we are
i'm learning a lot about you by the way
currently nice
[Music]
oh man what
what happened to me honestly i'm here
for
five years now i mean i've been making
music
no i'm making music no what i meant to
say was i make music and
i go out with friends and like do
regular is that like
was that not the like norm uh at the
time no i
i feel like uh back then i really like i
i focused on music and just ignored
everything else and
so you've learned to like chill yeah i
learn to chill balance it out you know
not getting
out uh i'm doing good man taking my
sweet time
what is drive safe by responding
about what i was thinking when i was
making the song was
you know talking to someone that you
that i love
and being like hey drive safe
be safe i love you sometimes i feel like
you know you talk to people and you kind
of take your conversations for granted
you say certain things that you can't
take back and
you know you regret it and when it's too
late you can't really say anything to
them but
you know i feel like this song is about
just appreciating the moments that you
have with people which i think is
important
you're really like digging deep today
these are very like poignant answers
thank you what
i'm sorry about that what nationality is
rich brian i'm indonesian
and i'm europe and indonesia yeah
jakarta
what language does rich brian speak
i speak indonesian and english english
is my second language
i didn't really start speaking english
to other people until i was like
12 having american friends and like
talking to them on skype
so i speak both languages okay
where is nikki from i am from jakarta
indonesia
born and raised homegrown where does
nikki shop
um hmm good question
online or like in real life uh
i'll answer i'll answer both uh-huh in
real life you'll likely
find me at whole foods okay okay
i was thinking of like clothing more
etsy
okay where does
nikki go to okay first of all
i'm no longer in high school i graduated
i'm 22 years old even though i may
not look it next one where is nikki now
los angeles california baby does rich
brian actually ice skate
no wait is this like one of your lot
like longest
standing like music video secrets
honestly no have you ever said that that
wasn't you
no no no i don't think i now you know
yeah
exclusively does rich brian
speak chinese i wish i spoke chinese but
i didn't
does rich brian have siblings i have
three siblings i'm the youngest out of
four does rich brian
have tattoos i do a few months ago i
impulsively made a decision to get two
tattoos
one right here if you see it in the
mirror it says manifest and
this one right here uh it's just like
three dots
does rich ryan have a driver's license
oh my god i feel like this is your
universal sign
that you need to go get a driver's
license yeah honestly though when i was
in indonesia
i got to a point i i took driving
lessons
and i was able to like drive around my
neighborhood and stuff that's cool
that's something yeah uh but
in america i feel like it's a whole
different ball game there are
rules yeah yeah yeah
oh it's back to me okay okay does does
nikki
have siblings yes i do have siblings i
have
two brothers i have one and he is
turning
10 this year and i have another one he
just turned one
does nikki drive so i just started
driving i'm a very new driver
and yesterday literally yesterday i
drove to target
by myself with plenty of left turns
diagonal parking all by myself
does nikki have pets yes i do
and if you meet me i will literally only
talk about my dog
her name's lucy okay next one does nikki
have merch
yes i do nikki dot story does nikki play
any instruments yes i do i play guitar
and i play piano and once upon a time i
played ukulele i can still play it but
i just stopped playing ukulele but i can
still do it yeah and then once upon a
time i played banjo like i kind of
taught myself how to play a banjo
i touched it for maybe like two days
yeah and i like
figured out how to play like one chord
it's cool so there you go there you go
does nikki write her
own songs no just kidding
yeah he actually he's my ghost writer
no yeah i do write my own songs kind of
very particular about it
so all right rich brian
best songs i really like cold
i feel like cold i was really proud of
yeah because i feel like it doesn't have
like it doesn't have a hook or a chorus
it's just like kind of unconventional
and it turned out to be like one of the
biggest songs for my first album
i like history history was cool history
is a good one yeah
yeah so i was like watching a video on
like a airsoft gun review
and in the intro they had that song
playing you know
and at that point i already had this
idea for like a chorus
wait so you're saying you sampled the
beginning of that video
i didn't sample it you recreated it you
got it
rich brian education i was homeschooled
since the second year of elementary
my mom had a really like interesting way
of teaching me things like she wanted to
teach me science
like first hand so she would like take
me and my brother on like
walks to like go see like plants and
stuff and she's like
yeah i think that was really fun it was
very much like diy
rich brian first song
i wrapped on this uh this mf doom beat
and i recorded it
on my iphone and i mixed it on sony
vegas which is a
video editing program and then i
uploaded it on soundcloud
and the picture was a photoshop picture
of me and tyler the creator
and i was wearing a shirt that says earl
sweatshirt is better
i posted it and you know people seem to
kind of like it
even though i kind of did it as a joke
and then that was like okay
i i want to make more songs and put out
on soundcloud
nice yeah rich brian
latest song from california it was me
and nikki and warren all three of us
just came together and
you know did the the the old avengers
and and just
made the song okay rich brian oh mbti
is that the one with like like infj enfj
i have no idea what i am actually i did
it a long time ago but i forgot
if i were to guess not that i know have
any knowledge on this by the way
i feel like you'd be like an i n
i s t
j it's like you explain introverted
sensing thinking judging sounds like me
rich brian next album
okay i don't know i don't know when it's
coming
making the sailor was such a such a
process you know that was like an entire
like year and a half of just like being
in the studio and like really thinking
hard on like okay
for this song the visual needs to be
this because it fits like this story and
like i feel like now i kind of want to
just be
like free i might put out like a little
mini project or
you know singles here and there and
features and all that but albums i'll
i'll i'll take my time on that i want it
to be good
what is nikki's what is nikki's short
for
what are you short for like yeah it's
just it's always been a dream
to just be short and like not be able to
reach anything
like in the grocery store it's really
cool it's a great life
what is nikki's zodiac sign zodiac sign
do you know this i think you're uh
january 24th so that's uh it starts with
an a
you're an aries no aquarius yeah you're
an aquarius
i'm an aquarius what is nikki's
favorite color uh i hate this question
like it literally changes every other
month
so you know a recent color that i really
like like a sage
green like i got a sage green throw
pillow recently against like my
like a cream couch like a neutral couch
do it i promise you it's beautiful what
song did nikki sing
in
[Applause]
raya and the last dragon
and the last dragon what if it wasn't
dragon it was
war paint the henry fong remix
why was rich brian
crying okay wait i'm assuming that
they're referring to the lose video
i cried multiple times okay that one and
then there's like a
like a selfie of me crying that's like
pretty
oh oh this one yeah yeah yeah yeah
um why was i crying in the lose video
just because the song was so good i was
trying my best to sing along but
you know the lyrics just like really
struck me so hard that i was
i couldn't hold the tears back right as
for the the selfie the crying selfie
i was on tour and i got sick which like
made me cough a lot and sometimes i
would have like cough attacks
right where i just couldn't stop
coughing and i would just like start
crying
and i was like you know what this is a
perfect uh time to take a picture of
myself
and it went viral yeah people like
people still use it okay
why is rich brian so famous
i mean i i make stuff you know i make
music
i make you're blessed yeah
honestly no that's that's the number one
that's a great uh answer i'm blessed
when i was 15 i started this thing
where i pray just to simply say thank
you
for like the simple things right and i
swear
since i started doing that my life was
just like
it's always good to be grateful for like
everything yeah you know
yeah yeah so that's why i'm famous
there you go and that is
all thank you guys so much for watching
thank you so much for googling us
and have a great day stay safe stay safe
you